dave mccormick exclusively i'm ingram
angle dave
uh thanks for being with us tonight i
know you're exhausted it's
this is neck and neck between you and oz
right now
he got back from uh he got the backing
from trump you
wanted it as did barnett and others you
didn't get it
but with these absentee votes at least
right now you seem to be
outpacing oz
if that holds what did you do to secure
that
well good evening laura thanks for
having me it's great to be with you and
i'm i'm uh excited about where we are
you know a couple days before
uh the election i think i was on your
show and i told you
that even though it wasn't showing up in
the polls i felt huge excitement and uh
and that definitely showed up yesterday
and i was really pleased with it was a
record turnout in pennsylvania
as you said with the three leading
candidates all uh
running on an america first agenda and
our campaign had put a lot of energy and
time
into focusing on these absentee voters
and focusing on our ground game and uh
and so that has paid off uh big
dividends and uh there's a huge number
of absentee ballots which we're winning
disproportionately and that's why i have
a lot of confidence i'm going to win
this because there's tens of thousands
of outstanding absentee ballots and i'll
win those disproportionately and uh and
that'll put me over the top and that's
what you saw happen over the last 12
hours or so
is uh mammoth oz's lead
got cut by more than half because of the
absentee ballots that came in
now dave in the last hour on hannity
show oz appeared we're going to play
part of it
we've covered all counties to ensure
that the ballots correctly counted this
election is ours we have done well
reaction to that dave
well listen um i see it differently but
but we'll figure this out soon enough um
i think that uh what happened was really
a groundswell of support for me
and uh and i'm really pleased with where
things stand and if you look at just
what's happened today uh what i've been
saying and i i said last night when we
uh when we uh sort of shut down for the
evening i said that there are tens of
thousands of absentee ballots that will
be counted and when they're counted um
i'll ultimately take the lead and we're
on that path and i think it'll be a
great moment for pennsylvania a great
moment for our party because it'll offer
the opportunity uh once we get through
this and resolve this
to bring our great party together and i
look forward to doing that i think
there's a great opportunity to bring our
party together around an america first
agenda that can go into november and
beat john fetterman and and the great
news is there's lots of uh independents
and conservative democrats who are
deeply offended by the extreme uh
liberal socialist agenda and uh and
that's an opportunity for us as
republicans to consolidate our party i
met a number of democrats former
democrats that uh came into our party
because of president trump and there's
more opportunity there well dave you
know the the new thing and we kind of
alluded to this last night the new thing
is that fetterman's a populist he's got
a sweatshirt sweatpants and shorts
athletic shorts obviously we wish him
well he's recovering from his
defibrillator
um insertion
uh but
do you buy that that he's he's gonna
fight for the everyman he just i believe
he just sent out a thank you tweet to
joe biden
uh for all his help
well i wish him well as you do uh and i
look forward to seeing him on the
campaign trail but but no i i don't
think uh it's authentic i think that
there's a uh there's a history there of
of a guy that uh you know uh went to
harvard and has a trust fund and
ultimately is going to have to defend
the extreme policies of joe biden which
which have been a failure they haven't
just been a failure for republicans
they've been a failure for all
pennsylvanians and all americans and you
can't run away from that uh it's obvious
with the inflation numbers it's obvious
with the war on energy that's made us
dependent driven up the price of fuel
it's it's obvious with the fentanyl
crisis we have in pennsylvania and uh
and john federer is going to have to own
that
well and you know fetterman is going to
be a vote for chuck schumer as senate
majority leader it's as simple as that
he's never going to challenge schumer on
any major issue now dave given your
background i want to get your reaction
to this jp morgan
is saying that gas prices will surpass
six dollars a gallon nationwide by
august that sent shutters down um
shivers down everybody's spine today
what would that mean for pennsylvanians
well it'd be terrible but that you know
the first thing i learned at west point
was accountability uh as a leader
and the thing that really offends me
about what's happening in uh gas prices
is joe biden's trying to blame it on
putin and when in fact it's the direct
consequence of these terrible policies
that have made us energy uh
dependent uh we went overnight under
president trump from being energy
exporters and on a way to energy
dominance to being energy dependent
that's what's driving up the price of
fuel and you know this of course it
hurts all of us but it hurts working
families
in pennsylvania uh and across our
country the worst it hurts small
businesses that are getting excited that
they're getting crunched right it's it's
a it's an absolute disaster by the way
it's also one of the main drivers of
inflation which is the silent thief
that's really uh really putting a huge
burden well
on pennsylvanians as well well dave when
you start to lose jeff bezos on the
inflation issue as a democrat that's
right
all right dave if if you pull ahead and
if if we expect you back on um this is a
fascinating race and uh we're on it
every night so thank you so much i'll be
back thank you get some sleep hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else